so before we get started let's get
something straight because someone had
mistaken this have to be Shrek it's not
it's Yoda all good they're great happy
to get my screen working all right okay
I think it's coming back thank you
all right cool so I'm gonna have more
security talks today which is I don't
know expect that I guess so introducing
myself my name is Aron tal I work at
sneaked as a developer advocate we build
developer friendly security tooling for
open source some of my other projects
that I'm involved with are nodejs I'm
part of the security working group for
the node foundation I also call Mako
maintain on the core team for our wasp
node goat I have a secret passion for
building sea alive so something like
that and a couple of years ago I wrote I
think one of the first books about
nodejs so essential no di securities
I've been doing this for a while and if
you want to talk about any of these
topics to welcome to ping me at Twitter
Charlie run underscore towel so in this
talk today I want to take you to a
journey of understanding some horror
stories some bad things that happened in
node security ecosystem as well as
JavaScript go through maybe if we have
time a small demo for one of the
vulnerabilities that is typical for node
projects and then kind of end with
positive note about about the silver
linings in node security so starting off
I think we've talked about it a couple
of times here in this conference NPM was
the biggest lego system you know has has
actually been almost surpassing 1
million packages probably this will
happen this year probably tomorrow or
something like that when more people
publish more interesting and
entertaining packages to the registry
and what I want to talk about is that
have been the biggest repository as NPM
is invites big risks as well so for
example it is a very lucrative
playground for attackers because
infecting malysh being having being able
to infect or compromise one package
translates into many many open-source
users of this package right and the
other thing is that NPM by itself is a
very open and free to
public repository so there's nothing
like an automated security review or
identification of who you are when you
submit something unlike things like iOS
and stuff like that so you're welcome to
submit and build whatever you want and
just send it off to the registry and at
this scale that NPM is right being a
very big big basically the biggest
repository of open source packages is
having scale issues how do you automate
finding malicious packages exploits
really bad code in terms of security
audit so all of those are kind of the
risks that we're seeing coming up and up
for a long time one of those is that I'm
going to talk about today is malicious
packages and want to look at it with you
together and see what's going on there
so when we talk about malicious packages
we can kind of translate them into three
ways that they manifest and one of them
is type of squating attacks the other
one is compromised accounts being
happening on NPM and so someone is able
to publish so malicious model on behalf
of someone else and unwantedly of course
and a social engineering way and all of
those we've seen happening truly
ecosystem in the car in the past a
couple of years what hadn't happened yet
and oh god please don't let it happen is
the NPM repository itself being
compromised so I hope that does not ever
happen but we can be you know wishful so
going back onto a timeline of
understanding how a malicious packages
evolve they want to start with something
that is kind of familiar but just would
go to this very quickly
so remember fall is a package that has
been put into the registry the way that
it acts as a package you can see the
package manifest and those of you who
aren't familiar with the package itself
but are familiar with NPM packages you
will see that there is a install script
that once you install the package you
would get your hard drive kind of
deleted it's a great package if you want
to delete you know browser history so
this is kind of what this is this is
built into the NPM CLI lifecycle right
this is how things work so when you
install something you give those
permissions cross and is a popular
package as well that was introduced into
the into the package registry basically
what it does is it allows someone to
manage environm
trebles so if you heard me or someone
else or the talk talked about it and you
wanted to go and install it and you
would have typed it like that you would
get something else not the actual cost
and package so what does it actually do
so cross and is a package malicious
package that is actually we can see here
actually bundling the real cross and
package right so it's giving you the
exact same functionality but then as we
have already kind of been noticing and
running here it also does something when
it gets installed it runs this package
setup script which when we look at we're
seeing that some things are kind of you
know odd and weird and not something
that a package should do
there's this host name remote host name
that's called NPM that hack stack that
net that is what this script does is
basically read your process dot n which
is your environment variables available
to the process basics T for encoding all
of that so that you know nothing maybe
get you on a walk or something like that
putting all of that into a post request
and sending it off so basically when you
install it it's gonna go and eat all of
your environment variables giving you
the exact same functionality no one
suspects it but at the same time sending
all of that to a malicious actor and I
bet no one is saving here passwords or
security and environment troubles right
good what we had that right so the type
was quoting attack right and what if I
told you that one of those NPM modules
for a very popular module are also that
was ported so take a second and try to
think which one of them is is that right
confusing both of them or typosquatting
attacks and this is not something that
happens you know two or three years ago
if I take a look at for example
vulnerabilities and you know packages
that we were tracking we can see that
malicious packages have been sent in
just two weeks ago this is 14 of my 2019
malicious package type was quoting
attack that was sent in just two weeks
ago trying to type was quite the popular
package request which is I assume
someone had done that because request is
kind of going on maintained etc so
someone is trying to write on the same
idea so what we learned so far we've
seen post install scripts we're seeing
scripts that actually when you install
them call home
to send some payload but the question is
how are we finding out about those
vulnerabilities right how are we finding
out about this malicious package so no
one caught it right now Nathan p.m. no
other player in the industry actually
developer cut it and posted it on
Twitter because he saw that something
weird is happening when he installed the
package and alerted Kent who is the
original order of the the Tok package
right across - and which is just fine
tears so this brings me to just when 18
just last year right meet last year get
cookies let's talk about it
it's an NPM package that parses HTTP
header so you can work with cookie data
or does it so in fact get cookies is
nothing less than a command and control
backdoor that allows someone to run
arbitrary commands when you install it
it is so elaborate in the way that it
was created that someone had actually
the malicious actor had actually put it
behind several levels or layers of
hiding it between something else
so someone understands how the how
complex the NPM ecosystem is so for
example if you were looking just that
get cookies to get it maybe you'd find
it but if you if it looks legit and some
other packages are actually bundling it
itself maybe you don't look you know
three levels down the tree to find it
and an NPM package the malicious package
like three of them on there in the
registry part of being a million other
packages as well you're not gonna find
it so we need to inject it into
something that is popular so maybe we
can put it into mail parser and that's
exactly what they did they injected the
top one into mail parser in some way so
let's look at this 44 lines of code
backdoor it starts with something that
should look familiar to anyone who has
been doing a node or Express development
it has a function signature of an
express middleware a route middle word
that takes the request on the response
and when this gets introduced into a web
web service like Express it allows
someone to do something with this data
what exactly so first of all this
backdoor allocates 64 bytes of data so
it can do something with that puts this
on this dot log buffer then you know
stringify is all the data from request
headers and tries to find a specific
pattern using these regex
to pass those commands that someone is
sending remotely for whatever reason I
don't know they had been able to format
it so this is a little Indian in Indian
I don't know if this is because they've
been trying to obfuscate it or make it
look complicated or not but as we can
see in the back door itself it has is
exposing three of those commands one of
them is actually always resetting the
data so it's trying to empty the buffer
or reset it from time to time if it's
needed the last command is actually
getting the JavaScript payload on to the
log buffer so whatever is get gets sent
is get loaded into the log and when it's
time to all the data all the JavaScript
payload basically had been transferred
over the wire it's gonna go and execute
it so it's gonna turn things into to
string require this hex encoded VM
module which allows you to use sorry to
use something that's called a function
that is available that's called running
this context and gives all them all of
the data so to simplify this the way
that this would work is someone would
just get you send whatever request to
this web server that he is available to
do use this pattern of G command H then
data and I and this exposes the whole
workflow so for example we're setting
that resetting the buffer would be GF e
FF right and if they wanted to load some
JavaScript code they would do something
similar and said this payload over the
wire when everything is done and
everything is over there we're gonna go
and execute it
so this this really this is of course a
real example right this is really what
happened we'd get cookies introduced
into into into mail parser and of course
this was a thing it's it's let's take
some observation here because it didn't
truly affect the entire the entire
ecosystem just because it was seen very
fast but also at the same time it was
seen that specifically mail processor
didn't do any use of of these gate
cookies of the of the top level HTTP
fetch cookies that was introduced but it
happened and all of this code is ruled
and made it to a malicious package that
was sent in a malicious version of a
specific package that gets downloaded
almost half a million times a month so
one observation that we can make here on
what
and is that if you were trying to code
review one package by you know one by
one and go to all of those packages you
know this will be a very time-consuming
and very difficult thing for you to do
so you need to get it right all the time
while attacker is trying to get lucky
once and maybe making it in let's talk
about the S link scope and see what
happened there that just happened couple
of months after after get cookies and
the essence is link scope is a child
package obviously in the project itself
so it's a very popular static code
analysis for JavaScript projects the
project itself of course was not
malicious just this specific version
that was published you can say it is
getting downloaded quite a bit and what
was going on there is very similar to
what we have seen actually before so you
already recognize this partner and
something when you installed it
something was calling a post Tyndall's
install script and running this Lib Bill
j/s which what it is was basically
similar to what cross on with it right
and if cross and was trying to to take
your environment variables then this was
actually calling paste pin care calling
a remote payload to get whatever
javascript was there and when it got it
it evaluated it so it received
everything back to quality or end PMRC
tokens which basically what happened and
send them to a remote attacker the thing
is what you put in NPM RC is very
important these are little tokens and if
you have maintainer you are publishing
packages then this gets important
because now someone is able to publish
packages on your name so it's kind of
like a JavaScript form that as more
people install it this spreads out and
more maintainer czar compromised funny
thing is if you are recognizing the code
and the mistake that was happening here
is it evaluated the JavaScript code on
an event getting the data so for example
this could be an issue if the data
itself didn't fit didn't fit into into
one a specific chunk of the data stream
that got him and this is how he found
out about it someone was basically
opening an issue saying oh I installed
the eslint scope or whatever and I got
this error what what's happening this
looks like a virus or something so again
another example of this problem in the
ecosystem and we have no automatic
controls on the NPM ecosystem and
registry to be able to cut to catch them
automatically so some
had to bring this up who depends on us
lead scope well just a few packages I
don't know if you heard of them but
basically kind of powering the entire
front end ecosystem so what happened is
NPM of course had to invalidate all of
this all of the tokens from the date of
this package making it in and you know
estimating almost 5,000 compromised
accounts so our observation that we can
make you right
yes lien school published an NPM package
but the malicious actors that were able
to get access to yes in scope didn't
have access to the github repository so
basically what happened there is that
the source code on github was different
from that on on on the NPM publish
module how does something like this
happen right we're talking about
compromised the malicious packages that
are not type was quoting it back it's
not someone deliberately making a
package malicious by taking someone
else's package and making it happen so
what if I told you that contributors
maintainers on NPM were actually
compromised what if I told you that a
security researcher had actually
compromised at one point in time
fourteen percent of all the packages on
NPM owed on NPM right it is 20 percent
it's accounting for 20 percent of all of
the NPM monthly downloads maybe you know
some of these packages right so all of
them at one point were indeed someone
was able to get publish access to all of
those luckily for us he is someone who
is working with us and a good citizen so
nothing bad happened but you understand
that this could have happened
how right how does something like that
happen how are you able to compromise
something like Express or react or debug
these are very popular packages that mod
is by millions of millions every day
well it turns out from his research
about 600 users use Diggs the amazing
password one two three four five six the
one of about one one thousand and four
hundred had used the password set to
their username which is a bit better
from one to six I guess and 11 percent
of them not understanding and realizing
the importance of password security had
actually reused the past
that was was I've been able to get to
get that from from a data breach so this
is something you know about the state of
security I think in general in open
source right maintainer is who we look
up to and you know what probably amazing
people but it lacks some kind of you
know best practices on basic things like
password security and if something like
one of those popular packages gets get
compromised and gets into malicious or
you know backdoors inside it where the
problem because we're all using that
everyone in this room is probably using
one of those packages I'm not going to
talk about it event stream too much so
just kind of to sum it up it's been a
popular story I think in the JavaScript
ecosystem probably one of the most
sophisticated attack that we've seen to
date there's a timeline that is building
a post-mortem to you know explain
exactly what happened there but that is
a different case from what we've seen so
far it's not type of scoring and not
compromised accounts but actual social
engineering attempt to send in a
malicious package that was able to
actually target specific developers of a
Bitcoin platform in order to make
transactions to to a third party and you
know II only found out about like two
months after it happened so definitely
one of the most important things that
we've seen so far if you're interested
to read more you can just go to this
link it brings a sec trailer observation
because specifically what happened with
the event stream was that the code for
the malicious package that event stream
included by itself was minified was
transpiled you know people used x great
today so even if you wanted to code
review and check source to publish
package it's not specifically an easy
task because the source can and may be
different from what you have on the
published package so it's not a
one-to-one match all the time this
brings us to talk about dependency
management right how do we track all of
this all of those packages that we have
npm a very convoluted place packages are
you know nested trees or are effing if
so to say a research had shown that the
the average def of any package is more
than four levels dipped
that's pretty big to to figure out
exactly what
going on in a package and many times
vulnerabilities come in from from just
indirect dependencies that you have in
your project or even if you are gonna go
and code review ever and go into you
know change logs and and use that are
for security issues for everything that
reactor Express or whatever brings in
actually most of the vulnerabilities
will come in from those indirect
dependencies the exact number is about
78% of the times when we find those
vulnerabilities we find them in those in
direct dependencies not in those they
not in the direct ones which we're going
to talk about this revelation where when
developers are building their apps you
know they are thinking that you're
writing a lot of code but in reality
their code is just very single and small
blimps on the radar in terms of the
entire application and this is something
that we're trying to raise awareness of
and you know taking more responsibility
in terms of developers building their
applications using open source software
so maybe let's try and do a 1-1 life
than what you kind of see also typical
vulnerabilities that we have affecting
the ecosystem all right so I have here
let me do that I have here this example
app it has an endpoint called about new
as you can see when I render something I
just I just call it it render something
on the string on the screen I am able to
give it things like device is desktop
and then maybe it it renders it a bit
smaller and if I did something like
mobile it will kind of make it which GSS
work make it a bit bigger and so far so
good if I were trying to find out what
happened here maybe I would understand
that this goes in something gets
evaluated maybe I'll try and escape it
some way so maybe I'll add like a quote
and figure out maybe I can escape
something that's happening but I can't
and let's see what what's really
happening so to give you context into
this basically this is the dust gs the
dust jeaious templating engine for for
for nodejs and it's very popular one not
as popular as maybe handlebars
but it's been used by you know thousands
of projects probably and as we can see
this actually has this escape HTML so
it's actually trying to do something
good right it's checking if something
that I'm sending is a string and if it
does it's gonna go and and and change
and escape all of those single quotes to
something that is encoded into the
correct context of HTML so that looks
okay except it's actually looking for a
string right over here go ahead and make
that more readable for you so it's
actually looking for a string but what
if you were able to send it something
that's not a string it would not go
through this
sanitization process so for what if I
were able to go and send something like
this
right so at this point in time maybe I'm
sending something else maybe I'm sending
I'm doing what's referred to as an HTTP
parameter pollution I'm basically
sending something that looks like an
array like an object so it's not anymore
a string in the JavaScript context but
when things get you know to string I'm
gonna get the first element and I'm
going to get desktop so when I do that
then I try to maybe escape it I'm saying
that something is actually happening
right just to give you an example of
what that looks like is something like
this so I know that something bad is
happening there and not every case is
covered and now I can go in and figure
out what is going on with the dust
helpers so what does tell press shows me
is that the way dust is built it's
actually evaluating some code some
internet into a condition so when I have
code in my template like this which is
by the way just fine right this is how
template engines work they need to
evaluate stuff and add some kind of
logic into something that you build this
data actually gets escaped and then I
can do a lot of stuff like inject code
into it so I can go ahead and do
something like escape it console.log it
and then I no need to escape it back
again so at that point in time I'm
actually able to send something in right
there we go
so as you seen I've been able to
basically append here a console log into
one and over here you see that server
actually evaluated one so evaluation
happening in the way that template
engine are supposed to work but it's not
always safe and this is an example of
vulnerabilities that we're seeing a lot
in open source packages all right so
let's go into the positive parts of you
know that the good part of the future
that's I think is is very interesting so
we can talk about NPM as an ecosystem
right and we talked about malicious
modules and typos floating attacks in
specific so how does NPM handle that so
there's react native for example if I
would want to type Oh support it I could
have maybe sent in a package a malicious
one that's called react native without
the dash or you know different cases of
it right now
is some kind of measures on the NPM
registry to disallow you to send these
kind of packages because what it's going
to do is gonna strip all the punctuation
mark like that I'm gonna try and compare
the packages and if they are close
enough you know they value the same
thing it will not allow you to send them
in and you won't be able to publish them
except that's not smart enough as we've
seen there are other ways of
typosquatting packages the recommended
way to do that of course is to create a
new scope and if you really wanted to
use you know this exact namespace you
could you could do it like that under
your own scope and use this and use
react native as it should be written
funny thing about NPM is at one point in
time it allowed the exact same package
to be created even if it's if it's
different in terms of upper upper case
and lower case so these are actually two
different packages on NPM the fact is
that right now we cannot break any one
of them because breaking it will
probably break the ecosystem so this is
something we have to live with for now
another thing that NPM had added is the
ability to send the notifications when
packages get published so this is kind
of related to malicious packages you
know being sent in terms of compromised
accounts someone might be getting this
notification of this package being
compromised and if he didn't of course
publish it himself it would raise
awareness so we have that as well to a
fee right EA we have to affair you in
the registry so it's been available
actually for almost two years you can
enable it from the UI from the from the
command line just like that I have a
quote here of Adam Baldwin the security
person inside of NPM saying a couple of
months ago that you know he kind of
cranked the numbers and found out that
about seven percent of NPM packages only
those have to have enabled which is a
bit of a sad story choose so of course
I'm encouraging everyone here to enable
2fa there's a flipside of 2fa right the
caveat for that is what happens if your
project and a lot of those a lot of us
maintainer is actually have those
automatic releases so we used to like
semantic knowledge to be able to once we
merge code it had passed all troll tests
we were able to go ahead and release it
so to effect how does that work in right
and you're able to create tokens
you can curate like a limited 2fa in a
way that it only works for login
attempts but not for publishing so then
you can use tokens but then tokens are
actually created for all of your
packages right for all of your user all
of the access that you have so even if I
wanted to use that that's not really
helpful because someone getting one
token is able to compromise all of my
packages and p.m. kind of recommends in
a chat with them to create a second user
the thing is the second user has the
exact same problem write all the tokens
created for that specific user are going
to be used for all of the packages that
that user uses so to actually you know
kind of limit it I would need to create
a specific user for every package that I
own
and then just use that single token for
every single package which is of course
not scalable so we're hoping to see more
more advancements in terms of 2fa on NPM
the developer is taking ownership right
that's a really good point and ownership
or application secure that's a really
good point that we're seeing a lot in
the industry so we asked you know
developers in one of the recent reports
you know who do you think should be
owning application security and I don't
know if surprising a lot or not but 81%
of them are saying that you know
developer to take ownership and of
course that doesn't dismisses or removes
the need for applicator for security
people right we're gonna need that
expertise all the time but the fellows
are simply stating they are taking more
ownership on like their docker files
right full stack development on the
cloud they want to be empowered with
good security tools that work in the way
that they work right they're not they're
not in to replace us they are not going
to be security experts so I think one
good attempt in that is now we have NPM
audit it already bundles in when you
install NPM and when you when you when
you scan something or when you just
install you get is get an audit with
something that may be malicious
but what if security was easier what if
security was more developer-friendly
what if it's something that you it is
not an afterthought what if it is just
another check on your CI to make sure
that nothing gets introduced in terms of
a vulnerable package
what if security was more actionable for
developers what if instead of getting a
report that you know two three four or
five whatever packages are vulnerable we
would instead be able to help developers
in this ecosystem in workflows that are
very familiar to them that we can open
cool requests to apply fixes right with
really smart tools we can I we can do
that and make them more powerful so
lastly I want to say a few words about
the night security working group which
is what a couple of us here are taking
part of I want to say basically you know
if you need any help with security we
are here for you right there is a
security working group working within
the node foundation and hopefully with
the open J's foundation kind of merge
maybe for the broader JavaScript
ecosystem we meet once a month
everyone kind of affiliated with
security expertise but you know at the
most part trying to better help the
ecosystem some of the stuff that we do
in terms of improving the ecosystem is
things that are related to node core so
for example a bug bounty program another
example is for example we have processes
and best practices so processes like how
do you release a new security release
for an old core how does that work how
do you announce it we maintain our own
hacker one bug bounty program as well so
anyone who wants to actually send
something unrelated to to node but
specifically to any NPN package can send
either and of course maintain our own
public vulnerability database out of all
of this knowledge so coming up and just
to give you an idea of what the thing
that the security working group has been
tasked with I do not know if you know
all of those models but react SVG you
know serv prod above basics before URL
some of those are nested dependencies of
others so you may not know them as
direct dependencies but you know
spanning millions of downloads all have
been tried and worked on from the
security working group and powering
tools like NPM audit and snake right
this is stuff that we are trying to help
the ecosystem so summarizing our talk I
think we talked about malicious modules
how contributors get compromised enable
to a PHA for that of course common
security pitfalls like code injection
happening through on the server side
through insecure ways of protecting code
and I think the future is kind of right
we're doing a lot of work in terms of
tooling in terms of involvement with a
security working group so there's a lot
of developer awareness coming out which
is I think is a very very very good good
thing you know fix and find
vulnerabilities in your open source
dependencies and just talk to us on the
working group if you have anything else
thank you so much if you want to talk to
me about anything related to nodes the
working group security open source
maintaining packages and difficulties
you're welcome to hit me up thank you